Asian representation shang-chi powers
and plot revealed mutants and Baron
Mordo awkwafina's role reveal she's
great
Jumanji that's the one she's known for
it's when the cosmic Wonder I'm excited
to check this out we'd haven't really
covered shang-chi all that much so I'm
very excited - yeah or decide I'm
excited let's do it
how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about old things
Marvel and everything relating to the
MCU
now sadly most of Marvel Studios as
projects both movies and shows that are
upcoming have been put on hold due to
the corona virus however some of these
projects have been working remotely
Marvel Studios has already had to
reschedule and rearrange their shooting
all the Shane TV is soon to this new TVs
have actually been able to get some work
done and shang-chi and the legend of the
ten rings happens to be one of those
projects and last night we actually got
some considerable details about the show
including what the main spot is going to
be the powers that shang-chi will have
people were upset those of you who may
not be that excited about shang-chi and
the legend of the ten rings it's like
some mutants may show up in the film now
morsi was the MCU they all lasting news
as well so we'll break down every single
thing that we know about shang-chi and
the legend of the ten rings if you're
new be sure to subscribe for your Marvel
content and also so you get into my Iron
Man Funko pop giveaway this week all you
have to do to enter is subscribe like
the video and come back and the subject
so today's legend from a fandom of wire
they are the ones who've got the
exclusive details about this and posted
them to their site and we learn a lot
from these new details including a lot
about the movie and these details even
match up with a previous plot leaked
that we got from a very reputable source
in the past and of course I'll be sure
to talk about that in this video quick
spoiler alert for anybody who is trying
to avoid any and all things about
shang-chi and the legend of the ten
rings if you're with me let's dive into
the plot in this film shame she will
have a special power and
cuz of it he was raised in an orphanage
for kids that are trained to fight this
special orphanage is run by the Mandarin
and before I'm not talking about that
fake Mandarin that we saw in Iron Man 3
hey driver bloody hell no I'm a movie
you want something take it
although the guns are will fake because
those wankers wouldn't trust me with the
real ones look team she would eventually
go on to somehow escape the school slash
prison and begins to live life on the
run and he goes through his entire life
trying to avoid and stay out of the
clutches of the Mandarin however despite
shengqi's best efforts the Mandarin does
eventually find the grown-up shang-chi
again and he has an offer for him and
this offer is a chance the Mandarin
comes to Shanxi money and power along
with the promise that he'll finally stop
chasing him if he will fight in an epic
and magical tournament that every kid in
the orphanage has been training for
their entire life
the legend denies which grants the you O
power which close the Mandarin ones
Tournament movie Li to open fight so he
enlists shame chief now according to
fandom wire this tournament that shame
she is going to be fighting in for the
Mandarin is going to have new characters
from all corners of the MCU that
included Wizards aliens fighters and
well-known comic book characters that we
haven't seen before and this is oh yes
Enter the Dragon characters Iron Fist
her second special power according to
fandom wire in this film Shang Shu
special power is going to be the ability
to clone himself while fighting now this
is actually a sweet thing she has in the
comics to a certain extent in the
character Hunter hunter create clones of
himself anytime anywhere for any type of
reason he could create a clone to simply
make dinner for him so he wouldn't have
to make it himself but according pilots
report his powers are going to be a
little bit different in the MCU
according to this report his powers and
the MCU are going to be kind of limited
in the film he's only going to be able
to project versions of himself during
fight sequences meaning he's only going
to be able to clone himself while he's
fighting
although this might mean emotional power
it doesn't really nerf it all that much
because he can still you
it for combat now fandom wire says that
they asked their source to provided them
this information what the fighting and
cloning is going to be like they ask
their sources if the film's combat is
going to be more like the movie the raid
as far as hand-to-hand combat is
concerned or if it's going to be more of
a sort of magical fighting synchro it's
over using the cloning effect and their
sources told them that it's going to be
a mix of both now one thing that's very
interesting about this report is that it
does mention the fact that Marvel
Studios knows great martial arts fights
in here man I was so happy the Mandarin
ended up being a fake and not the real
Mandarin that we knew from the comics
and the ten rings weren't even really in
the movie not the true ten rings at
least and the report says without
spoiling anything they do address this
in the film
so hopefully Marvel Studios will provide
some sort of retribution for Iron Man a
couple of terrorists a guard ten rings
came to service not too long ago and the
plot leaked details were pretty much
exactly as I just described but they
mentioned characters specifically some
of the characters that are going to be
in the tournament now all of these
characters are going to be fighting to
win the ten rings now for those of you
who are not familiar with what the
mandarins ten rings of power are I'll
explain because they are very very
powerful each individual ring on each
individual finger here may be our
specific power on the left hand the
pinky finger is ice blast that freezes
the air in its path and can lower an
object's temperature to almost zero the
ring finger is a Minto intensifier it
magnifies the Mandarin psychic remember
learning all this controls memory for a
movie where the index leader is flame
blasts it emits infrared radiation it
can cause air to in condense by igniting
its molecules and the thumb on the left
hand is white light and many many
different types of energy frequently
used as laser beams now on the right
hand the pinky finger is backlight it
creates areas of absolute darkness where
all light is absorbed and it's believed
to access the dark force the ring finger
is a disintegration beam it destroys
bonds between atoms and molecules
causing an object's cohesion to fall
apart but it needs twenty minutes
recharge time between uses the middle
thing
here is a vortex beam the user can
create vortexes and levitate objects and
even himself the index finger is an
impact beam it projects Kentucky will
win by cloning some 60 pounds of TNT and
the foam on the right hand is a matter
rearranger it can rearrange atoms and or
molecules of substances or speed up or
slow down their movements so as you can
see they are extremely powerful objects
when used together now the plot details
say that this is going to be an exciting
users guide 10 rings gonna compete for
the 10 range tournament in which the
prize is the legendary 10 rings an
ancient alien artifact that has been
protected for centuries the other with
the matter and get that out in this
tournament are a variety of D and C list
of Marvel characters other characters
that are going to be entered into the
tournament are going to be mutant
characters and this league states that
it's not sure if these will be the
introduction of the mutants to the MCU
but mutants that are known to appear in
this will be spiral Omega red and T ray
now by the time shang-chi and the legend
of the ten rings comes out it sounds
like there are going to be other mutants
introduced into the MCU beforehand and
based off of the description of
shengqi's power in the movie it sounds
like he may even be a mutant himself
even though that's not necessarily what
he was in the comics now the mutants
that are going to be competing in the
tournament all have some things in
common they're all extremely gifted at
hand-to-hand combat with a few other
abilities at it as well for examples
like Cyclops arms she also has enhanced
strength she has the ability of flight
telepathy and she is skilled it's like
an anime I love advanced and
hand-to-hand combat and also have
superhuman strength speed agility
stamina and reflexes but also has
carbonadium retractable tentacles in
each of his arms so kind of like
scorpion trainer advantage but he can
also self heal like Wolverine or
Deadpool making him a very fierce
competitor in this tournament and then T
ray is active an archenemy of Deadpool
in the comics he's somewhat of a zombie
and has vast knowledge of magical voodoo
rituals and as the report said there are
going to be some magical aspects to the
fighting that we're going to see but
here's where it gets really an
a leak says that Baron Mordo is also
going to be entering the tournament
because he seeks the ten rings for his
own purposes now I think that everybody
knew that Baron Mordo was going to come
back home he was set up quite nicely to
be the next villain of the next Doctor
Strange film in the post-credits scene
for Doctor Strange now when we left him
he had decided that there were too many
sorcerers in the world and he took it
upon himself to start eliminating them
however he would have had to realize
that Doctor Strange is not going to be
an easy opponent in fact the ancient one
in Avengers endgame revealed that Doctor
Strange was supposed to be the best of
them she went forward in time and saw
what he would become and since more
dough before Doctor Strange was her
right-hand man it's more than likely she
revealed that information to him so yeah
man you can't shoot what so edge of our
great naturally if he's been keeping up
with the events that have been happening
he has a fighting background very
important role in defeating Thanos so
he's most likely going to be trying to
get the ten ring so we can eliminate
Doctor Strange and the rest of the
sorcerers now to top it all off this
report says that aquafina is going to be
playing a fought low sweet in the comics
she is shang-chi sister but in this new
updated version of the story she is
going to be playing the mandarins
daughter and then Tony chih-wei Leung is
going to be playing the Mandarin so let
me know what you won't think about this
does this sound like an exciting story
for shang-chi and the legend of the tin
ray yeah sure to let me know what you
think in the comments down below don't
forget to leave a like on the video and
subscribe to stay scrapped because you
care hey man you know I just want to say
I feel validated because I did do that
movie fights a long time ago at a
WonderCon it was a little bit after
endgame came out or infinity war one of
the two I was up against who which MCU
villain should returned and I picked
Mandarin my opponent trisha hershberger
she picked Red Skull lost by like just a
little bit but now that there's nothing
about Red Skull coming back Pam is all
about Mandarin shang-chi I win the big
game and that's what I think you won the
long game yeah
on the movie studio validation just
trying to protect my ego I loved
everything I heard about this because it
does remind me of all those like I grew
up on the movie Enter the Dragon a bunch
I mean we've all played and was most it
was a play Mortal Kombat or even seeing
the movie a lot of those fighting games
are technically you know tournament
based video games Tekken included so I
like the idea of making the plot
surrounding that I grew up on like Hong
Kong cinema if this rumor is to be
believed or if this leak is to be
believed the fact that they're doing
this just feels like the best way to
showcase the martial arts Asian side of
the video and on top of that if this
relationship dynamics that Warren's
talking about in this video with
Mandarin running an orphanage
essentially helping to raise Shane Chi
and his youth I love that dynamic
because it makes it more personal it's
kind of like in Tekken when Kazuya and
Heihachi in the Tekken games Hachi runs
the tournament but Kazuya or you know
you could even throw Jin in there or
like the main characters in that world
it feels very traditional and it's also
just a great excuse to get a whole bunch
of great martial arts fight scenes
showcase the powers we've been watching
hunter hunter lately on the patreon did
you have a tournament event that it
really is on display in season two I
love the idea of mixing both martial
arts but also honing in on characters
with like super powers like person with
tentacle arms person with multiple arms
so being able to do both where you got
really hyper stylized martial arts
choreography but also working with these
super abilities would just make for
awesome cinema a very slight concern the
Mortal Kombat movie is also coming out I
don't know if that's a tournament base
movie because if that Mortal Kombat
movie is a tournament based movie which
is gonna be a hard R and there's people
who do martial arts and have superpowers
in it and then you get this one which
will be like a pg-13 version I don't
know if this will feel diluted in any
way yeah then I can reshoot at three on
a train and
it's true that's a very slight concern
but everything we're hearing right now
like the shang-chi character sounds
great that clone inability sounds
awesome I think it'd be fun if he did
get some type of Trevor Slattery cameo
in the movie and I would love that like
it's somebody who does not outright hate
that twist I would I would have fun with
that because they do have the Marvel one
child words like the Mandarin does want
to meet you it would be funny if he had
a cameo in there or if there was some
type of thing in the background words
like that head to head of Trevor
Slattery or something yeah or you know
some crossover in the timeline because
it seems like this will at least
incorporate a few years of shengqi's
life and stuff like that maybe you'll
see in the background what was happening
in Iron Man 3 true or something like
that
this thing with Aquafina those switching
the character possibly to being the
daughter of the Mandarin are they gonna
try to work some type of love story in
there cuz usually when I hear something
like that it's usually what I think of
what it will probably go down either
that or maybe they could make a slightly
more sophisticated choice and maybe
they're like super close like they're
brother and sister or something like
that but the Mandarin and the allegiance
is you know the relationship and the
triangle they're like I would more
expect it to be a romantic thing but I
kind of hope it could be something like
that because it would make sense
especially if he grew up in this you
know orphanage hydrants running and
cheese is done like yeah there's a lot
of potential across there and also as
far as character changes go going from
sister to mandarins daughter seems
pretty big and significant but also it
seems not too big to be you know like a
Trevor sled or anything they don't man
going mad well that role if they're
gonna use her in a way that I sort of
imagined kind of like etana in Mortal
Kombat I feel like that would work I
like the idea of this feeling like just
a traditional tournament martial arts
movie in the MCU world I'm really drawn
to that concept sure look do their own
weird unique things with it following
the structure of those kind of movies it
sounds great to me oh yeah I mean that
was what was so fun about watching this
particular report right here is like the
more it went on the more I was just
visualizing and kind of seeing things
and oftentimes those are very familiar
and during this I was like thinking of
things that aren't familiar and this
seemed like a truly good chance for
Marvel to a again you know mix up the
tone and style but also yeah borrow from
a wide array of places because you
mentioned
in the reaction I thought that was a
great call because like anime video
gaming yet classic martial arts film
seems like ideally what they're going
there and I think that would be a great
palette it fits right in with a lot of
the themes of the MCU but would bring a
different character and story dynamic
and yeah getting a tournament movie like
throwing it back I feel like it probably
would in that case throw it back to
something like Enter the Dragon pretty
you know yeah vocally but yeah even
having that promise of the raid style
action meets some of that Marvel CGI
with the copying and stuff like that if
they can really balance that that could
be a cool new niche to see that's
something that has all the
bone-crunching precision of something
like the raid but with the spectacle and
with the you know fun stuff that these
superhero movies have to offer
I think the fighting style should be a
little bit more akin to something like a
new and looping style of like matrix
Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon kind of
fight sequences this room what I'm
hearing do if you're gonna mix like the
fantasy elements and especially when you
already got some of the people from the
raid in the new Mortal Kombat movie I
feel like I'm comparing it a lot but
come on this is like a Mortal Kombat I
just think for differentiation purposes
especially with your fight scenes they
would move them I think if like the
Mortal Kombat people have more of the
raid fighting style and then this one
had more of like matrix Crouching Tiger
fighting style instead and then Baron
Mordo coming back in this would be
better I think than going straight into
Doctor Strange multiverse of madness
granted I do think there should be a
payoff where he does end up going
toe-to-toe again with Doctor Strange
maybe in the third Doctor Strange movie
but you could use this movie to help
accentuate or build up his character for
some reason my mind is telling each it
with all of the for has some type of
martial arts background whenever I've
seen him do martial arts even in the
first Doctor Strange you really seemed
like he knows what he's doing he doesn't
look like a stiff actor who's been
trained for the movie you know my
question is though is like will the
Mandarin actually be surrendering the
ten rings as I like that idea of their
that's what they're competing for I just
don't see why the character immigrant I
don't know
with the execution of this dude's gonna
be I just don't see why he would give up
the ten rings for this competition
unless they twisted around or something
like that and they make it at a point
where he like doesn't have them for some
reason or whatever kinda strange for the
manner not to or he's letting them all
eliminate each other's that way he could
eliminate the most powerful threat that
could be orally but then again there's
that relationship dynamic that is being
talked about here where there seems to
be he wants to be like the father and
change his life perhaps there's some
type of manipulation tactic that's up
his sleeve that we were just not aware
about some ulterior motive everything
I'm hearing about this sounds really
awesome in it and I want more attention
around this movie we're all focused on
my multiverse of madness the Disney Plus
shows and of course they're people who
are excited for this me personally this
is the one I'm most anticipating and
then it would probably be multiverse of
madness just because of the amount of
characters that get introduced but as a
big fan of martial arts cinema it seems
like my jam right thanks more for
putting this together and reporting on
this because this was great subscribe
for cosmic wonder what do you think of
everything that you heard about in this
video subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell to get
notified never got a video up last but
not least Michael B Omni media homeboy
has been posting so much on his YouTube
channel if you want to keep up to date
with a lot of like DC TV show reactions
you should really follow this guy he has
wonderful reactions great reviews it was
actually his birthday recently so I
wanted to say happy belated birthday to
you I know that when you have a birthday
during this time of the pandemic it'd be
kind of a bummer because you can't
really have a big celebration my
understanding you were able to at least
hang out with a few of your friends and
you told me you went on like a four-hour
walk with them I hope that you're
putting that cardio to good use by being
with Sam your girlfriend in the bedroom
and displaying that cardio as hard as
fast as you can cuz if you're able to
walk for four straight hours like that I
can only imagine that you could probably
last at least based off my own metrics
my personal best rate at least five
minutes
I'm pad if you drink got a good day if
you haven't worked out yet if you have
some alcohol you can pry last five
minutes that's just based off of me
applying that to you hey have some
alcohol do some cocaine you'll get seven
minutes out of it seven minutes in
heaven go check out the Omni media
YouTube channel today